[Musique]
il n'y a pas de morts je peux fermer les
yeux
j'aurai mon paradis dans les coeurs qui
se souviendront toute sa vie maurice
genevoix à porter la parole des morts la
parole de ceux de 14
l'écrivain survivant de la grande guerre
fait aujourd'hui son entrée au panthéon
avec lui ce sont aussi ses camarades de
trancher les tuer les disparus les
blessés qui deviennent immortels l'enfer
de la guerre maurice genevoix l'a connu
à 24 ans jeune normalien il est mobilisé
en août 1914 il participe à la bataille
de la marne puis aux terribles combats
de la crête des éparges près de verdun
grièvement blessé en avril 1915
touchée par trois balles il perd l'usagé
de sa main gauche et est réformé
l'ancien poilus se plonge alors dans
l'écriture fidèle à ses fantômes ses
camarades morts au front
il rédige de 1916 à 1923 cinq ouvrages
sur la guerre ou au père 1949 sous le
titre de ceux de 14 partout nos passions
les petites croix se levait derrière
nous les deux branches avec le képi
rouge accrochée nous savions même pas
combien nous en laissions nous marchions
nostalgiques de l'enfance amoureux de la
nature maurice genevoix écrit aussi sur
la campagne qui l'entourent sur la loire
qu'il aime tant il obtient en 1925 le
prix goncourt pour raboliot un roman sur
l'histoire d'un braconnier en sologne
passionné de voyages il se rend de pays
en pays pour donner des conférences
ces livres racontent aussi d'ailleurs en
1946 reconnu par ses pairs il est élu à
l'académie française
émerveillé par le monde il est aussi un
précurseur de l'écologie a traversé
bestiaire ils célèbrent en mots et en
dessin la puissance de la terre et des
animaux jusqu'au bout il se consacre à
l'écriture il meurt en 1980 à l'âge de
89 ans d'une crise cardiaque laissant
plusieurs roman inachevé
quarante ans après sa disparition cet
humaniste rejoint côtés de ses frères
d'armes
les grands hommes et les grandes femmes
de france pitié pour nos soldats qui
sont morts
piti pour nous vivants qui étions près
d'eux pour nous qui nous nous battrons
demain nous qui mourront nous qui sont
frits ronde en enchères mutilé pitié
pour nous force à deux guerres qui
n'avions jamais voulu cela pour nous
tous qui étions des hommes et qui
désespère on ne jamais leur devenir